Bánh chóng ngày 3,5 mởi thông báo dệnh thương mại từ giòn xong dòng và phần diện.
A ủ khoai nè, nâng cấp đã chính thức có hiểu lực từ ngày 20,000 người.
Thưa đã hiện đệnh biểu trình phạm vý và mức độ tếp cảnh thị trường cho tương nhóm năm 3.
Đồng thời yêu cầu cầu các nhà sản xuất u khoai nè, dân đã bứng tư chuyển trình lượng và ăn toàn quay ủ.
Bánh bản cũng thế là cơ trế bảo hủ thương mại, nhẳng ngân ngờ dùi xói bình đồng thị trường, đã biệt trong lĩnh vận đung nhẹ.
Dù đưa xem là bất tiến trong tiêm trình hội nhập kinh tế của u khoai nè với ủ, khip định mới này,
bánh giữa một số dưới hạp đáng tế, đối với hạm xuất khẩu từ kế.
Sau khi dù đồng hạu khoai nè, nổ ra ủ tương tậm giữa bảo thủy nhất khẩu đưa với năm 3,
khi năm 3 cho ủ lòng ngày về cảnh tranh không công bằng,
việc khip định lưng cấp có hiểu lực lực được kì bảo mở sễ tạo ra sự gân bằng mối,
dân như cầu hỗ trợ khoai nè và bảo vệ lưỡi của các thình viên ủ.